Transcriber: ÖZGE İŞBECER
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Herkes merhabalar.
Arkadaşımın da dediği üzere
benim adım Arda Erkan.
Bugün size burada kendi kesişmelerimi
anlatmak için buradayım.
Nasıl başlamam gerekiyor?
Bence şöyle başlamam gerekiyor.
Ben üniversiteye geçtiğim zaman oda
arkadaşım benim liseden arkadaşımdı
ve liseden beri yapmayı çok sevdiğimiz
bir şey vardı.
Boş zamanlarımızda neler yaptığımızı,
yaptığımız şeylerin
bizi nasıl etkilediğini düşünürdük.
Neler yaptık, neden bunları yaptık, neden
buradayız, bu kararlar bizi nasıl etkiledi
gibi düşünceleri sürekli düşünürdük
ve bu sefer bunları benim sizle düşünmem
ve sizlerle bunları paylaşmam,
size kendi yolculuğumu anlatmam için
sürem gerçekten kısa.
Ancak konuşmam kendi ömrüm
kadar uzun olmalı.
Hayallerim kalıplara sığmazken
size bunları özetlemem lazım.
Size hayallerimi anlatmam lazım.
Hedeflerimi koyup
bu hedeflere ulaşma çabam boyunca da,
strese nasıl katlandığımı,
nasıl ayakta kaldığımı,
nasıl odaklandığımı
ve neden bu kadar odaklı olduğumu
sizinle paylaşmam lazım.
Bunları anlatırken ayrıca beni bu hayalde
neyin yönlendirdiğini de bulmam lazım.
Bütün bunların yanında önemli kararlarımı,
yol ayrımlarımı anlatmam lazım.
Hangi kararım beni tam bu ana getirdi?
Neden bu karar bu kadar önemliydi?
Bunların hepsinde cevaplarını ben bile
tam olarak bilmezken yapmam lazım.
Bu yüzden bu kısa süre benim için de
gerçekten çok büyük bir yolculuk olacak.
Belki kendi amaçlarımı tekrar keşfedeceğim
belki de neden yanlış yaptığımı bulacağım.
Bu yolculuğu size
belki kendinizden bir parça bulursunuz
amacıyla anlatmak istiyorum.
Sizden de isteğim ben bu yolculuktan
geçerken, ben yolculuğumu anlatırken
lütfen siz de kendinizinkini düşünün.
Ben önemli kararlarımın üzerinde durdukça
siz de kendi kararlarınızı sorgulayın.
Ben hatırladığım ilk olaylarımdan
başlayarak en önemli olaylarımı
adım adım anlatırken, siz de lütfen
kendi hayatınız için aynı şeyi yapın.
Sonunda umarım güzel bir yere varırız.
Yolculuğum tam talihsiz bir olayla
başlıyor diyebiliriz.
Bir trafik kazası, hatırlayabildiğim
o anla ilgili gerçekten çok az şey var
ve zaten hatırladığım şeylerin pek çoğu da
gerçekten duymak istemeyeceğiniz detaylar.
Ancak sizinle olayın ancak
kendi üzerimdeki etkisini paylaşabilirim.
Bu kadar travmatik bir olayın,
benim kadar, o zamanki halim kadar
küçük bir çocuk üzerindeki etkisi
tabii ki de büyük oldu
ve ben bunu söyleyebilecek kadar
uzman değilim.
Ancak şimdi düşündüğümde diyorum ki
bu olay beni
gereğinden fazla hızlı olgunlaştırdı.
Bu cümleyi ortaokulda fazlasıyla
duymuştum, yaşımdan olgun diyorlardı bana
ancak o zaman nedenini
tam olarak anlayamamıştım.
Şimdi düşününce mantıklı geliyor.
Bir insanın başına gelme olasılığı
bu kadar düşük olan bir objeyi,
bir olayı çok küçük yaşta yaşadım
ve o anları hâlâ hatırlıyor olmam
benim üzerimde etkisinin
ne kadar büyük olduğunu gösteren
önemli bir noktası bence.
Demem o ki, büyük sıkıntıların, sorunların
etkisi üzerimizde
azımsanmayacak kadar çoktur.
Kişiliğimizi şekillendiren en
önemli olaylar,
bazen de yaşadığımız sorunlardır.
Yolculuğumun ikinci noktası, ortaokul.
Ne çocuk ne gençsiniz!
İnsanların sizinle
çocukmuş gibi konuşması size dokunuyor
ancak genç olmak
korkutucu bir detay o yaşlarda.
Genellikle bu
yaşlarda hızlı öğreniyoruz.
İyi şeyleri, kötü şeyleri.
Ancak ben ortaokulda beni bu hâlime
getiren en önemli olaylardan
bazılarını yaşadım.
Üzerimde etkisi çok büyüktü bu olayların.
İnsanların pek çoğu ile bu dönem tanıştım
beni bu hâle getiren.
Günlük hayatımda nasıl konuşacağımı,
nasıl öğrenmem gerektiğini,
neler yaptığımı, bu işleri en iyi şekilde
nasıl yapacağımı
bu insanlar bana öğretti.
Benim yolum,
bana bu becerileri, en iyi şekilde
öğretecek insanlarla kesiştiği için
ben bugün bu insanım.
Sizin yaşadıklarınızdan
çıkardıklarınız kadar
size bu duyguları yaşatacak insanlarla
karşılaşmanız da aynı derecede önemlidir.
Kiminle karşılaştığınızı
asla küçümsemeyin!
Büyük küçük demeden, herkesi
can kulağıyla dinleyin!
Tek bir cümle ile bile hayatınızı
değiştirecek birileri olabilir.
Şimdiye kadar anlattığım her şeyi
anladığım dönemse benim lise dönemimdi.
Aklımda bu dönem için
gerçekten büyük hayallerim vardı.
Neler yapacağımı belirlediğim,
kim olacağımı seçtiğim dönem olacaktı.
Hepsini de yaptım
ama ne bu dönemde tanışacağım insanların
benim hayat planımı değiştirecek kadar
büyük bir etkisi olacağını düşünebilirdim
ne de bu dönemin sonunun pandemi gibi
büyük bir olayla bitip beni
9 ay alanıma kapatacağını düşünebilirdim.
Ancak ne olursa olsun, yaşadığım şeylerin
bana kattıkları inanılmaz bir seviyedeydi.
Bu konuşmayı ailemle de
pek çok kere yapmışızdır.
Bu okula gelmeseydim,
bu okulda yaptığım şeyleri
yapmamış olsaydım,
asla şu anda bu noktada
bulunuyor olmazdım.
Kesinlikle bugünkü ben olmazdım!
Ne bu şekilde bir topluluk önünde
konuşma becerisine sahip olabilirdim,
ne kendime güvenim bu kadar olurdu.
Aldığım tek bir karar, o dokuzuncu sınıfta
o tarih sınıfında duran çocuğun
tek bir yere gitme kararı, hayatını hiç
beklemeyeceği bir şekilde değiştirdi.
Aldığınız kararlar geleceğinize
çok büyük etkiler yapabilir.
Ben tek bir kararla, 4 sene boyunca
kendimi değiştirmeyi başardım.
Bu karar bana o kadar önemli gelmemişti ki
daha büyük bir karar
hayat başarınızı da getirebilir,
sizi yerle yeksan da edebilir.
Sonunda şu anki dönemim.
Gerçek hayatın, gerçek sorunların
başladığı denilen üniversite dönemim.
Her insan için büyük bir basamak oldu,
benim için de öyle oldu.
Çok kısa bir süre içerisinde,
7-8 ay içerisinde hayatımın
en önemli kararlarını aldığım,
en önemli anlarını yaşadığım dönemdi.
Daha ilk günden ilk dakikadan
tanıştığım insanların bana kattıkları,
bana yaşattıkları deneyimler,
hayatımı nasıl değiştirdikleri,
nasıl güzelleştirdikleri mi dersiniz,
kendi kararlarımın etkilerini nasıl
gördüğüm mü dersiniz bilmem ama
üniversiteye çok özel bir yer denmesi
gerektiği söyleyebilirim.
Çok farklı, çok özel deneyimlere
kapılarını açan, hayatın iplerinin
tam anlamıyla bizde olduğu bir dönem
üniversite dönemi!
Düşündüğümüz, hayal ettiğimiz her şeyi
başarabilmek bizim elimizde.
Bu 8 ayı benim için bu kadar önemli yapan
bu kadar mükemmelleştiren kararlar
bu kadar önemli insanlar olmasa
belki şu anda yine bu şekilde
burada konuşuyor olmazdım.
Bugün burada sizinle paylaşabileceğim
şeylerin bir üniversite öğrencisi olarak
çok kısıtlı olduğunun farkındayım.
Ne sizinle paylaşabileceğim önemli
deneyimlerim, ne büyük çıkarımlarım,
ne de size verebileceğim tavsiyelerim var.
Bugün sizinle paylaşabileceğim,
Benim yapabileceğim tek şey, farklı bir
düşünme şekli, bir sorgulama yöntemidir.
Bazen tek başınıza hayatınızı
neyin etkilediğini,
bu durumun sizin üzerinizde ne
gibi etkileri olduğunu fark edemezsiniz.
Farklı bir bakış açısı, bazen de
size eşlik edecek, sizi yönlendirecek
bir insan gerekir.
Aynı düşünceyi söyleyeceğiniz
sizinle birlikte yaşayan birisi gerekir.
Ben bugün size elimden geldiğince
o kişi olmaya çalıştım.
Lütfen siz de zamanınız oldukça,
kendi başınıza düşünün.
Hayatınızı neler ve kimler etkiledi?
Bu kişiler olmasa hayatınız nasıl olurdu
ve kararlarınız bundan sonra nasıl olurdu
anlamaya çalışın.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)